[Music]
5 25 on your Monday well tomorrow night
into Wednesday you won't have much
choice but to avoid the area where the
95 meets the northern 215 Beltway it's
time for another round of
Centennial bowling
so as the Nevada Department of
Transportation Works toward
2024's completion of the Centennial Bowl
they are shutting down both directions
of the 215 Northern Beltway from Durango
all the way over towards Jones starts at
7 30 Tuesday tomorrow night closure also
includes a couple of ramps in the area
so you won't be able to get from the
north 95 to the West 215. they're also
shutting down Sky point now that last
part is going to linger after the
Beltway schedule to reopen at five
Wednesday morning because the eastbound
Lanes of the 215 are shifting for the
building of a new bridge in the area all
of this information is in the online
version of the story along with a link
to ndot's Centennial bowl web pages when
you visit 8newsnow.com you click traffic
then driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone and
you can join the driving you crazy
conversation at traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com